[موسيقى]
الملك فاروق بن ناريمان الملك فاروق
وفريده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحاجات اللي عندنا في البيت في حاجات
احنا وارثينها يعني انا خدتها من بابايا
لانه كان بيحب الحاجات دي في حاجات كتيره
خلينا بقى انا وعلياء علاء اساسا قبطان
بحري
فهو كان بيسافر كتير من قبل حتى ما نعرف
بعض كان بيسافر فكان برضو دايما بيتجه على
الحتت اللي فيها تحف الحتت اللي فيها
الحاجات القديمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نفسي يبقى كل بيت فيه لوحه نفسي الفن
التشكيلي الفنانين يبقى لهم قيمتهم انا
دايما اقول يوم اما الفنان التشكيلي لما
يبقى في الشارع ماشي والناس تجري تتصور
معه انا هحس ساعتها يعني انا مش عايزه
حاجه بقى من الدنيا بعد كده انا عايزه كده
خلاص يعني
يعني ده اقصى محاطي
بيانو ده يخص الكريوي اسماعيل
فبقت عيني عليه اللي هو انا عايز اتعلم
موسيقى باي شكل وطبعا بقى مع التحف
والحاجات اللي زي كده فانت شايف الجمال
قدام عينك على طول والالوان جو مهايا
للاعصاب زي كده
[موسيقى]